haha
all right everybody tense up
haha actors out of this the province
[ __ ] with me Tom cameras on me now
what the [ __ ] is the line I forgot
maximum alert melon have some confetti
should ms maxim of manipulates molecular
allow her to vote for oh would you like
another one moving on same thing that
should happen to you
psychological around Oh mother yep see a
smooth mother come walking towards you
Wanda vision is really hurt in the
feelings
while a great many people see you as
heroes there are some would prefer the
word vigilantes
so much of the civil war story is told
from Captain America's point of view
we've brought in Tony Stark to showcase
that other side of that argument and
it's really the two of them and the
people that team up with them but at the
same time we thought it would be fun to
introduce a third side to introduce a
character that audiences have wanted us
to introduce for many many years who
comes in and is really not agreeing with
either side in particular and can
represent sort of fresh eyes to see
Tony's side of the argument to see cap
side of the argument and frankly to not
necessarily care about either side of
those arguments because he has his own
agenda and that's the chala the black
panther
kevin was like hey will calling you
about this character that I think you're
interested in I think you know who I'm
talking about and I say yeah I think so
are you interested in playing him yes it
was really that simple chadwick is a
really smart interesting dynamic guy
I think Marvel is so consistent at
bringing on such fine actors it really
feels like he's added to this group and
this presence on set I think raises the
stakes a little bit for everybody
growing up I was a black panther fantasy
black panther come to life is really
kind of like a dream come true
Chad gives him a great energy he gives
him a great confidence a stoic nough
still that character needs